today the Matt Walsh show a large antifa
mob attempts to derail my what is a
woman event at University of Houston it
was the largest protest I've encountered
yet and it had no effect at all also the
Parkland Mass shooter escapes the death
penalty AOC is berated by hecklers at a
sparsely attended Town Hall Democrats in
Virginia want to take your child away
from you if you fail to affirm his
gender confusion and an NFL coach has no
time or patience for race-baiting
reporters all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay
well for those who've been following the
story Vanderbilt Hospital has agreed to
pause all gender transition surgeries on
minors a big win a a left-wing
institution caving to pressure from the
right doesn't happen very often deserves
some recognition but the fight is far
from over there's still so much we can
do to protect our children from these
evil leftist indoctrination attempts one
thing you can do today is uh write a
will many new parents don't realize how
important it is to have a will in place
sad truth is that if you were to die
tomorrow without a will the fate of your
children will be left up to the state I
don't know about you but I don't want
the state to decide anything for my
family luckily my partner is over at
Epic will will make early estate
planning incredibly easy and affordable
they bundle your last will living will
Health Care power of attorney HIPAA
release and durable Financial power of
attorney bundle all that together plus
you save 10 percent when you use code
wall should only costs 119 dollars for a
single person to create a will and when
you use promo code Walsh you'll save 10
so go to epicworld.com use promo code
walls to save 10 on Epic Will's complete
will package that's epicwill.com promo
code Walsh
So Yesterday concluded the first leg of
my what is a woman College screening
tour will be back on the road in a
couple of weeks fittingly our final stop
on this portion of the trip was the most
eventful I would say as I had previously
reported on this show the antifa cell in
Houston had promised to show up and shut
the event down which is at the
University of Houston meanwhile far life
far left activists on campus had been
working on the University within the
university to cancel the event before it
even began but the event happened anyway
with hundreds of students waiting in
line a line stretching around the block
to get into the screening of our film we
packed an auditorium which unfortunately
could only hold a fraction of the people
who wanted to get in I'm not going to
say that what is a woman is the first or
only documentary to sell out College
auditoriums across the country but it is
uh certainly in a small Club I think but
while large crowds gathered inside there
were large though still significantly
smaller but uh crowds of protesters
outside who came together to voice their
strident objections to truth and reality
they attempted several different tactics
to I guess scare me away earlier in the
evening they stood in a line and in a
very direct sort of way they chanted
about what they want let's listen to
that
[Applause]
when do we want it
what's up
[Applause]
no what do we want yeah
oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
so I think they want me out is what I'm
getting from that I like it Trails off
at the end and they get kind of lazy and
then they just at first what do we want
wall shout what do we want it now and
then that's too much effort so then at
the end it just turns into now now now
um it's a subtle message anyway but I
think I picked up what they were trying
to say I think I did
soon there were various speakers who
arrived with bullhorns to fire up the
crowd and lay out their indictments
against me here's one who describes all
the many ways that I have invited
violence against the trans community
if we're calling his supporters to
action and Boston Children's Hospital
supporters threatening a children's
hospital with a bomb
Vanderbilt University Medical Center
resulting in the hospital submitting
gender affirmative care because of this
and other comments it's important that
Lexus cougars show up and say loud and
proud that we as students do not support
this
I was my inflammatory language that
resulted in Vanderbilt suspending their
child mutilation program evidently my
words are so scary that the hospital
simply bent to my will out of sheer
Terror and fear now I would like to
think that I am that intimidating and
Powerful I wish that was the case but uh
in fact that's not the case they
suspended their gender affirming care
quote unquote program because they could
not defend or Justify mutilating
children after those practices had been
exposed so that's how that's actually
how bad this stuff is that um all we had
to do was point it out and say look what
these people are doing and within a few
weeks they just stopped doing it you
know that's a that's like a pretty good
indication that someone is doing
something wrong where you know if
they're doing it and all you have to do
is point to the fact that they're doing
it and they stop doing it pretty good
indication that it's wrong indeed the
fact that they stopped doing it
actually proves that I was not using
inflammatory language they admit in
their letter to lawmakers announcing
that they're pausing the procedures that
my report was correct and they in effect
admit it because they they say they I
mean they had to have been performing
gender transitions on minors in order to
pause them it would seem
there was also this speech that I
enjoyed from another protester though I
feel a little bad that Stephen Crowder
and Andrew Tate catch some Strays here
for no reason but here's what she says
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
protect us
yeah but
but I did get away with it I mean I I
thought I could get away with it and I
did
I got away with it and it was great I
not only did exactly what you didn't
want me to do but I had I had fun while
doing it it was a lot of fun
yet still really think about the
phrasing here I'm gonna just skip over
the part where I'm a cockroach that
cockroaches that have she was attempting
a metaphor there she's trying to get
poetic but cockroaches that have crawled
out of the dirt of hate to spread their
you know let's put that aside uh the
phrasing that that actually disturbs me
a little bit more is um he thinks he can
get away with this I mean like get away
with what exactly
existing speaking saying things
expressing a point of view
much is revealed about the leftist
mindset just from that one statement I
would say anyway the crowd outside grew
more and more Rowdy as the night went on
police had to arrest at least I think at
least one person as far as I know when
the speech concluded uh the mob stood
outside cussing at and harassing the
audience
as they left the building and uh and
there's a lot of videos there that a lot
of fun that you can go watch because you
know my audience I'm very proud of them
the way they handled it they started
chanting let's go Brandon back so that
was great there are also some some early
on earlier on before the speech there
were some counter demonstrations of
people standing and and praying saying
the rosary while these satanic lunatics
scream at them you just as always you
see the contrast there and you can kind
of decide whose side you want to be on
but they then the protesters stood
around for a while longer even after all
the the crowds had cleared out I was
gone and they stood around around for a
while longer chanting various slogans
including this one
wow
yeah they ran out of slogans by the end
of the night they did nothing left and
so they were left with that for some
reason I got to tell you that uh I I
derive a lot of pleasure from the fact
that at this point when the crowds were
screaming F Matt Walsh over again I was
already back at my hotel sitting at the
bar with a glass of whiskey so there
could not be anything more impotent than
crowds screaming in protest against an
event that already happened while the
guy they're protesting is relaxing at
his hotel out of earshot
though they did attempt to do more than
simply scream uh outside I should say
I'm told by yaffe that
leftist activists on campus had been
sort of plotting to sabotage the event
by infiltrating the audio visual team
that's running it behind the scenes you
know amazing doing something with the
live stream or doing something with the
uh with the audio in the auditorium it
seems that one of them actually tried to
execute this plan the daily wire reports
this morning quote those trying to watch
the young America's Foundation live
stream of Matt Walsh's University of
Houston speech Thursday night were met
with an unavailable video and leftist
students student employees are being
blamed yaffe wrote following the event
that it believes it is likely that
student employees who opposed Walsh's
speech disrupted the live stream part of
the speech was seen on yes YouTube page
but poor audio made it impossible here
what Walsh was saying the live stream
later became completely unavailable
quote one of the student workers Kai Lai
was in communication with members of a
leftist coalition called stop
transphobia at uh and shared that she
would be working behind the scenes after
yaffe became aware of the student
student workers posting she was removed
from the event and a bomb sweep was
conducted this according to Nick Baker
assistant editor for yafs the new guard
according to Baker several student
workers were required by the university
to remain on site for the event and had
access to yeah streaming equipment in
the hours before Walsh's speech earlier
in the night a person protesting event
was wrestled to the ground and
handcuffed by police video the incident
showed the mass protester who had made
it inside the event venue on the ground
and surrounded by five police officers
who were attempting to arrest him the
protester appeared to be carrying a
small transgender flag that ended up on
the ground beside him so they couldn't
get in the room
but it looks like they were able to mess
with the live stream and uh so they so
they did that no big deal really there
are three other live streams from the
what is Woman tour available in the apps
YouTube page there will soon be several
more
besides the live stream is secondary the
most important thing is the event itself
like the physical event which none of
these screaming lunatics were able to
prevent or derail despite their many and
varied attempts
they were in the end powerless
and this is something that I want
the protesters at this and any
forthcoming universities to understand
but of course I will do precisely what
you don't want me to do and say what you
don't want me to say and there's there's
nothing you can do to stop it
you are powerless
and that's something you just have to
deal with
I know that you're accustomed to making
demands and having your demands met
but that's not the way it's going to
work this time okay I want you to know
how little your feelings
mean to me
I I want you to know that literally
nothing you say has any effect or makes
any impact I want you to know all of
that
so so so so often in your life you know
you you stomp your feet and you cry and
you get results and that's how you get
the results but I want you to know that
it's not going to work that way here
and I want you to know all of that
because it's a learning opportunity for
you
it really is it's character building I'm
trying to help you I want to help you
it's evident that most of you didn't
have fathers who would teach you this
lesson didn't have fathers at all in the
home that's extremely obvious
and so I'm trying to stand in the void
for you
you need to be able to cope with the
fact
people have ideas that differ from your
own
you need to be able to make peace with
that reality
or don't make peace with it honestly I
don't give a damn it's your problem
either way my only point is that it's
good for you to encounter a situation
every once in a while where your cry
bully tactics just don't work
and that's especially the case here
because it's not just that I have
differing ideas from you
it's the it's that the ideas I'm
expressing
are simply true
self-evident obvious
okay you aren't just protesting
different ideas this is not I'm not
sitting here saying that you need to uh
the diversity of viewpoints you need to
accept the diversity of viewpoints I
mean you should be able to accept that
but that's not even what we're talking
about here
you are protesting the truth
that's what makes us all so pathetic and
disturbing
there have always been protests on
college campuses there have always been
differences of opinion
but you're trying to protest and silence
the truth
that's the issue
and to call for the suppression of Truth
is insane and tyrannical
you are tyrants
pathetic ineffectual laughable tyrants
but tyrant's all the same
now let's get to our five headlines
NBC news reports the house select
committee investigating the January 6th
Insurrection presented previously unseen
video Thursday of congressional leaders
pleading for help from Governors
the acting Secretary of Defense and the
acting attorney general's rioters
attacked the capitol
the video montage began with house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi walking through the
capitol
and I've lost interest already so that's
still happening they're still doing this
in case you didn't know they're still
doing the generation another hearing
let's move on
um we actually begin here okay this is
this is in fact an important story so
this is from the daily wire a Florida
Journey a Florida jury rejected the
death penalty Thursday for the Parkland
school shooter who killed 17 people on
Valentine's Day 2018.
the shooter received life in prison
without the possibility of parole for
each of the murders causing
disappointment and frustration among
family members of the victims attending
the trial Dr Ian or Elon
Allied
alhadef who gave a moving Victim Impact
statement in August on the murder of his
daughter Alyssa it's a 14 year old
Varsity soccer player he says what do we
have the death penalty for we're Beyond
disappointed with the outcome today and
his wife Lori said I just don't
understand this
um another victim who lost a daughter
says I don't know how this jury came to
the conclusion that they did today but
17 families uh did not receive Justice
the shooter was in the penalty phase of
his trial having pleaded guilty to 17
counts of murder last year 14 students
and three staff members were killed with
the youngest victims only 14 years old
Okay so
they're not giving him the death penalty
this is uh
truly absurd and a miscarriage of
Justice this guy is in his early 20s I
think so he's like 22 23 years old
something around there
taxpayers will have to pay to keep him
alive for the next
six decades seven decades
um
why
like why what's what's the point of that
I I to me it's it's a very it's a very
simple equation
that if you've if you have done
something which necessitates that you
can never return to society again
then you shouldn't be living anymore
you have given up your right to live
uh
we we know that the right to life is not
unconditional
somebody breaks into your home
um and has a gun you don't have to allow
them to kill you and your family because
you're respecting their right to life
they have forfeited that they have
chosen to Forfeit that through their own
behavior
it's not what you wanted it's what they
wanted
and they've left you no choice
and we could say the exact same thing
about uh
about someone who goes and kills 17
people 14 kids
at a school
you have left Society no choice
but to just get rid of you the ultimate
punishment that's Justice
and of course to make the absurdity to
make the you know the irony even more
outrageous here is that I talk about the
right life well
um you know there's the I think the
misguided belief among some pro-lifers
that they have to take this absolutist
position on the right to life and and
and declare that well because we defend
the rights of babies to live that means
we also have to defend the rights of
convicted murderers and monsters to
continue living
and uh and that's you know there are
some pro-lifers to do that and I I think
it's I think they're mistaken
but at least there's a certain
consistency there that they're trying to
establish
but as we know many of the people who
oppose the death penalty and who I
suppose are happy today that this
scumbag is not going to be executed many
of those people don't even believe in
the right to life or certainly don't
believe in the right to life for babies
I mean there are it would say millions
of people in this country who believe in
the right to life for this guy
after he killed 17 people but not for
the babies
that's how twisted and upside down all
of this is
if you're going to have the death
penalty at all I mean if it exists as an
option
it just it it does not make any sense
that this person would not be eligible
for it
there's nothing else to be done
did you spend the rest of his life in
prison uh there's no you know it's not
like we're there's no there's no we're
not reforming this person and trying to
reintroduce them to society
although who knows in some states in
some cities if he had been tried and
convicted there maybe they actually
would try that
try to reintroduce him to society that's
not going to happen here
um he's going to be sitting in a cage
for the rest of his life
and what's the most just thing to do
well it's to tell them okay here's the
date of your execution and by the way
it's not gonna be 30 years from now it's
going to be soon like I don't know next
week
you got a week to get right with God if
you can
but either way this is when it's coming
to an end for you this is this is the
end of your story here on Earth
it's a tragic ending but it's the one
you chose
that's what we should say
and I also I I I don't really totally
understand this idea that's uh you know
that people say well it's a it's a
horrible thing for the state to execute
someone to state to kill the state has
no right to do that
well why would the state have no right
to execute a murderer
but the state does have the right to put
you in a cage for your whole life
that's that's another thing I don't
quite understand
all right
this is from the daily wire
representative Alexandria Casio Cortez
struggled at a town hall event on
Wednesday evening when two attendees
confronted her for allegedly supporting
nuclear war
I mean personally editorializing I would
take the allegedly out I think in effect
she does support nuclear war and that's
that's what happens I mean everyone on
the Democrat Party that are uh you know
wanting to confront Russia and
potentially get us into a nuclear war
that is what they're supporting
um so this would appear to be we'll play
the clip here but
this would appear to be I don't know a
lot about the the people that are
protesting here confronting her but
these would appear to be people on the
left
so maybe these are left-wing anti-war
people I didn't even know those existed
anymore but there are a few of them out
there and here's uh what that looked
like
congresswoman none of this matters
unless there's a nuclear war which you
voted to send arms and weapons to
Ukraine
he's left the Democratic party
okay you originally voted you ran as an
outsider yet you've been voting to start
this war in Ukraine you're voting this
Russia and China why are you playing
with the lives of American citizens
you're playing with our lives there will
be no neighbors if there's a nuclear
bomb you voted to mobilize and send
money to Ukrainian Nazis you're a coward
you're a progressive socialist where are
you against the war mobilization he's
telling the right truth you have done
nothing Tulsi gabbard has shown guts
where you've shown cowardice I believed
in you and you became the very thing you
sought to fought against that's what
you've become you are the establishment
and you are the reason why everybody
will end up in a nuclear war unless you
choose to stand up right now and denial
the Democratic party will you do that
yes or no
okay simple are you going to stop
nuclear war yes or no
there is no line because this is
[ __ ] none of this matters if we're
all dead none of it you know that
[Music]
let's take it up right now because this
is the only thing that matters
this is the only thing that matters
right now because I'm just enjoying this
video to be honest with you but a minute
and you can accept it
that's what's going on that's what
happened there all right
I mean I I love that that's exactly what
needs to happen uh this is exactly and
this is you would come with politicians
there should be a lot more of this
Direct
um Angry confrontation this is what they
deserve this is what this is what a town
hall should look like I think
that's actually this is a healthy kind
there are people that see videos like
that like oh it's it's so much division
this is terrible actually in a healthy
country
um that's what a town hall with a
politician looks like
especially a politician
who's in the party that is in fact
moving us towards nuclear war
advocating for pushing us towards
helping to fund and facilitate a
confrontation with a nuclear power over
Ukraine
and yet none of these people
for the for the many months that this
has been going on none of these people
have been able to explain why exactly
Ukraine should matter to us that much
why should it matter so much to us that
we are willing to to risk World War
nuclear war over it
they've never been able to explain that
the most they can do is they give us
this this nonsense about uh well we're
standing up for democracy and freedom
democracy and freedom in a country 5 000
miles away that has nothing to do with
us whatsoever
also assuming that Ukraine one of the
most corrupt governments on Earth cares
about democracy and freedom in the first
place which obviously is absurd
so she's confronted for that and and I
and I based on what the protesters are
saying there it does seem as though they
are on the left so yes this is a this is
the rare a very rare spotting of a
left-wing anti-war protester there used
to be a lot of those back in the I can
remember when I was younger back in the
bush years
uh code pink and all those it was very
common
um but in recent years they've seemed to
have gone away almost entirely
until they confronted Alexandria Casa
Cortez the other thing you notice in
that video
is that the room is almost completely
empty
and that's one of the reasons why these
uh these protesters were able to have
this confrontation is because the room
was empty and so their voice carried and
everyone could hear them and and Cortez
didn't have enough of her own supporters
there to boo this these guys out of the
room
uh that is maybe the most interesting
thing to me about the video is that
there's almost nobody in the room
now you expect to see this with a lot of
politicians and we expect to see this
with Joe Biden
but Alexander Casa Cortez she's uh
the biggest star in the Democrat Party
she is
who's Big who's the bigger star in the
Democratic party but aside from
Alexandria Casa Cortez she's the most
well known the one of the most
well-known anyway she's a household name
for better or worse I would say For
Worse
so she is their star and here she is
holding a town hall and almost nobody
shows up
I think that really tells you something
all right climate activists through uh
tomato soup this happened this morning
uh through tomato soup on a van Gogh
painting at the National Gallery in
London so first we have the footage of
them
committing this act of vandalism let's
play that
all right so Priceless work of art
deface it with tomato soup
and now they pull out their uh Super
Glue
and they're going to glue their hands to
the wall
this is all this is all to save the
environment
you have to understand
now how does this help save the
environment what exactly what's the plan
here
so I know if we look at the at the
step-by-step plan
the goal is save the environment step
one
throw tomato soup on a Priceless work of
art step two glue hand to wall
step three
question mark step four planet is saved
so I'm not sure what what happens in
this what are we missing in step three
well the they were interviewed while
they were sitting there glued to the
wall and they tried to explain they
tried to kind of square this circle and
let's hear that
what more than Justice are you more
concerned about the protection of a
painting or the protection of our planet
and people
cost of living crisis is part of the
cost of oil crisis
is unaffordable to Millions
families they can't even afford to heat
a tin of soup
uh I think a good punishment with these
sorts of things is and I could see maybe
why the art gallery wouldn't be a fan of
this but I tend to think a good
punishment is just to leave them glued
to the wall just leave them there
and it's the same thing they've done
this at Starbucks where they glue or
their hands to the to the counter to
protest I forget what they're protesting
at Starbucks
um oh they're protests because there
aren't you know very often they protest
at Starbucks because there aren't enough
um non-dairy
options for cream like they want more
oat milk and that sort of thing I think
but anyway in the same let's say the
same thing there just leave them glued
and if you're not going to do that then
I then I actually think that years in
prison is is the appropriate response
here that would be Justice
you come in and deface Priceless works
of art you should be going to prison for
you not you know not jail for a day even
though even that much they probably
won't get
we should be looking at 5 10 15 years in
prison
and that's what a society it's what a
serious Society a serious culture would
do
that's how you protect your art
you send the message that this is you
cannot do this this is unacceptable
that said I will uh I will admit that I
have a bit more sympathy for these kinds
of people than say the Leonardo
DiCaprio's and Al gors of the world
at least in a way in a way they have the
courage of their convictions very stupid
convictions
I grant you but it's there
and the other thing too is that they
actually believe this stuff so when you
see these younger climate activists who
are uh gluing themselves to walls and
defacing things and blocking traffic and
doing a lot of really annoying things
and things that are much worse than
knowing in fact are are horrifically
evil uh but also keep in mind that
they've been have to make excuses for
them but they have been brainwashed from
a young age and they really do believe
this this is what they've been told they
believe that the Earth is where we are
barreling towards destruction and
apocalypse they really believe that
up unlike a lot of the older people that
are
bankrolling this movement and are really
behind it and pulling the levers who
don't believe it at all
right here's a
really awful story this is from Fox News
it says a neonatal nurse in the UK who
allegedly murdered seven babies and
attempted to kill 10 more wrote notes
reading I am evil and I killed them on
purpose because I'm not good enough
according to the prosecution Lucy letby
32 who worked in the neonatal unit of
the Countess of Chester Hospital left
handwritten notes in her home the police
found when they searched it in 2018
earlier this week Johnson argued it's
Nick Johnson who's the prosecutor he
argued that letby was a constant
malevolent presence in the neonatal
units of the babies let be allegedly
murdered or attempted to murder between
2015 and 2016. the prosecution said that
she injected some with insulin or milk
while another she injected with air she
allegedly tried to kill one baby three
times
this is the story maybe you've seen in
the headlines of this neonatal nurse
that's a serial killer of babies
and you hear about a story like this and
and obviously it's Unthinkable it's
horrible here's another person that
should be hey this should be a
easy case for the death penalty we
shouldn't even have to think about it
obviously this is a death penalty
candidate
although being in the UK it's probably
that's not going to happen
um
but you it is also worth noting in fact
I you can't help but note
that this woman working in the neonatal
unit
that would mean that her victims were
probably all uh not only infants but
they were born premature that's how they
ended up in the NICU
one of the most common ways to end up in
the NICU is you're born premature
so she's killing premature infants
and we all look at this case and every
single person who sees this case we all
recognize it as unbelievably evil
we see this woman I think this is one of
the worst humans on Earth
we all agree with that there's no
disagreement
and yet
you put a Planned Parenthood badge on
her
you change the context just a little bit
but you have her killing the exact same
babies in a slightly different context
not only now is it all of a sudden legal
but there are people who defend it and
would say that that in fact she's a
she's a hero she is a heroic
practitioner of reproductive Health they
would say
killing the exact same babies
at the exact same stage of development
only difference is you take these babies
and you take that you take the crime and
you put it in a building that says
Planned Parenthood on it
in this case the babies are still inside
the womb of their mothers
rather than in the NICU
and somehow that changes the moral
complexion of this case
completely we're told
which is total nonsense
all right I also need to mention this as
we uh continue along I think I may have
to return to my home state of Virginia
based on this report anyway out of
Virginia let's watch this
a new bill centered around parents and
how they handle their child's sexual
orientation and gender identity 7 news
reporter Nick menock explains why this
is controversial
right now parents rights and lgbtq
protections are a big focus in Virginia
thousands of students in Virginia have
walked out of class protesting Governor
Glenn younken's newly proposed model
policies on the treatment of transgender
students at school
and Governor young can argues schools
shouldn't keep parents in the dark about
their child's sexual orientation and
gender identity please
these same progressives in Fairfax
County
actually believe that they should lock
parents
out of their children's lives
they think that parents have no right to
know what your child is discussing with
their teacher or their counselor a
democratic Virginia delegate Elizabeth
Guzman is a social worker and she's
planning on reintroducing the bill in
Richmond that she says would help
protect lgbtq children from their
parents and Guardians who may not be
affirming of their child's sexual
orientation and gender identity this is
how we're gonna push back her bill would
expand the state's definition of child
abuse and neglect to include parents who
do not affirm their child's gender
identity or sexual orientation there's
an investigation also in place that is
not only you know from a social worker
but there is also a police investigation
before we make the decision that there
is going to be a CPS charge what could
the penalties be if you know the
investigation concludes and it's
concluded a parent is not affirming of
their lgbtq child what could the
consequences be well we first have to go
have to have an investigation you know
it could be a felony it could be a
misdemeanor but we know that CPS charge
could harm you know your employment
could harm your education and Alexandria
Nick menack 7 News
and delegate Guzman tells 7 news that
she is home well you have to realize of
course is that this is in so this is in
Virginia where as we heard of the at the
beginning there obviously uh Glenn
yonkin is the governor so that means
that this bill is not going to be signed
into the into law right now in Virginia
but this is what they want to do
um and this is what they will do
especially in blue states where they can
get away with it
make it a it is child abuse
to not affirm
so-called affirm your gender confused
child they're already doing this in
Canada
this was uh this is It's A couple of
years ago they declared that it's and
their their anti-conversion therapy I
think was Bill C4 in Canada
which uh which forbids conversion
therapy but what is conversion therapy
according to them it is conversion
therapy if you do not affirm your
child's confusion
so if you're if you have a son who is a
boy and says he's a girl
and you do not immediately accept him as
a girl then you are committing
conversion therapy
by trying to convince him that he is
what he in fact is which is a boy
so if you in other words if you do not
facilitate his attempted conversion
into another sex which is impossible
then you are guilty of a conversion
therapy
and that's child abuse you could lose
your kid
and parents in Canada have lost their
kids because of that
now the left wants to do the same thing
here uh in the United States
I saw someone on Twitter I don't
remember who but they uh you know
referred to this as kind of it's a we
know on the left they had their no fault
divorce policies
and for married couples
and so now what they're working on
basically is a no-fault divorce of
children from parents
they're looking for every way that they
can to sever that relationship sever
that Bond
and in the schools they they do it they
sever the bonds psychologically they
sever it emotionally
they turn parent the child against the
parent
but now they're looking for ways to do
it legally
just tear the kids away from the parents
and into the arms of the state
where the state can make of them
whatever they want
that's what they're looking at doing
all right a lot of heavy stuff let's go
to something a little bit less heavy
well this is celebrity gossip so a
little less serious I suppose uh this is
from the Sun this is Gisele Bundchen has
broken her silence following her recent
alleged marriage troubles with Star
Quarterback Tom Brady bucks quarterback
uh Brady and the Brazilian model have
reportedly hired divorce lawyers
following an epic fight
and she was spotted visiting a a
spiritual healer earlier this week we
heard about that
um but she broke her silence how did she
break her silence okay well she replied
to a post on Instagram that read here's
what the post read
you can't be in a committed relationship
with someone who is inconsistent with
you read that again
the 42 year old commented below it with
a prayer Emoji which I guess is her way
of agreeing so this is what qualifies as
breaking silence now
your first public statement is an emoji
God help us but I'm mostly just reading
this to you because I I want to say that
the relationship advice here is really
terrible
you can't be in a committed relationship
with someone who's inconsistent what
does that mean
I mean if by inconsistent you mean
Unfaithful then sure yeah but then just
say unfaithful
if by inconsistent you mean someone who
is I don't know prone to shifting moods
someone who sometimes says one thing and
does another someone who doesn't always
follow through someone who doesn't stick
to what they say they're going to do all
the time if that's what you mean by
inconsistent because that's what comes
to mind when you think of an
inconsistent person if that's what you
mean and you're saying you can't be in a
relationship with that kind of person
then you're really saying that you can't
be in a relationship with anyone ever
because that describes all people all
people are inconsistent some more than
others but all people are and that's
that just comes with being a weak
temporal mortal
uh human being inconsistency it is a
defining human characteristic
one of our most
uh consistent traits is inconsistency
ironically now the key to having a
successful relationship
is learning how to love and be loyal to
someone
even in spite of this frustrating defect
that we all share
now I'm not saying that that
inconsistency in all cases should be
tolerated or just accepted or that you
should resign yourself to your spouse
being unreliable I'm not saying that
what I'm saying is that if you're
married you're married to a human being
and you need to know that you need to
understand what that means you're not
married to a robot even less to an angel
you're married to a person and persons
disappoint they frustrate they irritate
they let you down sometimes all people
do this
if you can't love someone in spite of
that then you can't love and and you
won't love
and you won't be loved
and you'll be alone alone with your own
inconsistencies your own fickle
frustrating nature uh until you die
okay so this is I I
know this is just a cliche marriage
advice that someone posts on Instagram
but um it has an effect on people you
hear enough of this and they start
believing it
and it's just nonsense
finally the New York Times has an
article revealing that on average
um now for pollsters people doing
political polls only point four percent
of the people that they call actually
pick up the phone and complete a survey
so that's the report they had and I'm
surprised it's even that high
but this this brings up an issue I've
always had with polls all polls and
we're seeing a lot of polls heading into
the midterms but this is especially with
political polls and it's why I tend to
believe that all political polls are
fake like they're all bogus none of them
mean anything at all and the reason is
that there's such a vanishingly small
percentage of people who will even take
them in the first place
it's only a certain type of person who
would take a political poll over the
phone a freak to be specific a lonely
weird bizarre person
who actually will talk to a stranger on
the phone about his political opinions
so when you see a poll and it says that
so and so is leading by however many
points
it means what you have to how you should
interpret that is that among the lonely
weird bizarre demographic demographic of
people who answer polls
this person is most popular
and yet that demographic is so small as
to be uh irrelevant from an electoral
perspective so who cares and forget
about taking a poll
I've never
taken a phone survey in my life or even
been asked to take one but the reason
for that is that I don't pick up the
phone to begin with if I don't recognize
the number
so well I don't pick up the phone for
anyone to be honest but but especially
if I don't recognize the number I'm not
picking up the phone so who are these
people where you get a call on your
phone you don't recognize the number and
you pick up anyway rather than letting
it to go to voicemail if they have
something important to tell you then
they'll tell you in the voicemail so you
pick up the phone that even though you
don't recognize the number
and then it's something someone on the
other line says I want to talk to you
for 15 minutes about your uh about your
political opinions and you sit there and
just talk to them rather than hanging up
that I don't understand
what's sick satisfaction do you derive
from that kind of masochistic behavior
is what I want to know
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
s
Aaron Jeanette says it seems that we see
more girls regretting their transition
and boys I find it interesting and
haunting uh yeah that is uh that is a
notable thing it is interesting that
when you we hear about D transitioners
and it seems pretty much anytime you see
someone telling their stories the
transitioner
um in the vast majority of cases it's a
girl
and what's the reason for it I think
well one of the big reasons that comes
to mind immediately is that the vast
majority of the people who are
transitioning in adolescence are girls
so I think that explains why the
majority are um the of the transitioners
are girls now I think that'll change
over time because what we see
is that and this is we know this
statistically that among adolescents
vast majority of people experience the
gender confusion and going through
transitions are girls we know that now
it seems to me and I don't have the
numbers for this but uh this is my
estimation my guess is that for younger
kids
it seems the majority there the majority
of younger kids who begin transitions
seem to be boys
certainly when it comes to the the cases
that get a lot of
a lot of attention from the media like
anytime we hear about some five-year-old
who's being transitioned and the media
is telling us about it and celebrating
how wonderful and accepting the parents
are in almost every case it's a boy
transitioning into a girl
um
so I think give it another 10 years or
so you're going to see a lot more
detransition males who are in their 20s
but right now because this is such an
epidemic among adolescent girls that's
why that's where you see most of the
regret
all right
Stephanie Marie says a few years ago I
went without a phone for about two to
three months mine broke and I just
didn't bother getting a new one for a
bit and that time I noticed an extreme
decline in my anxiety in the morning an
increase in activity I woke up and
instead of checking my phone right away
I went right to yoga breakfast working
Etc it's a shame that we need to we need
small computers on US 24 7 for work
while people manage without them for
hundreds of years
yeah if you could kind of detox from the
phone this is uh this is seems to be the
what what most people say if you can
detox from it put it down
leave it alone for a certain period of
time
um you you have this incredible impulse
at least for a period to go pick up the
phone but if you can get through that
detox period
you'll come out on the other end feeling
a lot better I know this for my this is
certainly the case for me because I go
through these minor kind of detox
periods anytime I go on vacation like
when I go on vacation I have I actually
have no problem putting my phone down
and not looking at it when I'm on
vacation because I know I'm not working
I have no responsibilities and so
whatever it is whatever the period of
time is I can put the phone down not
even bother with it I have no I don't
even have the temptation to pick it up
but then you come back and uh and it's
almost at first getting back from
vacation at least for me picking up
social media again it's almost it's like
a chore I have to force myself
to develop the impulse again and then I
do and it becomes an impulse
it's just very
it's very sick and unhealthy Josh says
I'm 100 in agreement with all this stuff
but I might be even more agreement with
your quick comment about making beds
every morning I've never understood it
at all my wife does it because she says
it makes her feel more organized or
something like that but to me it's just
wasted effort when I push off the covers
in the morning if I leave it there then
that night I lay in the same spot and
pull them over me streamlined as going
to bed should be
yeah I've had I think this is a classic
argument especially between uh husbands
and wives but I've tried to have I've
tried to explain this to my wife
like she goes through this we wake up in
the morning it's not just making the bed
like she makes the bed she and it's like
she tucks the covers underneath the
mattress uh and then then she has all of
her pillows as I've complained about
many times she has 50 pillows that she
puts on the bed and so then every night
when it's time to go to bed we gotta
take the pillows off and there's nowhere
to put all these extra pills just end up
throwing them on the ground
um you know pull the covers out from
underneath the mattress
it is wasted effort think about all the
cumulative hours of my life that I've
wasted doing that
um
James savely says I wish there was a way
to force every adult in the U.S to watch
one week of the Matt Walsh podcast
I couldn't agree with you more
and when I am Theocratic fascist
dictator
of the world
then your dream will become a reality
because that will be a requirement
although not for a week of course every
day
so a few weeks ago on the show I read
you an email we were uh that we were
copied on from a Harry's Razors customer
who was canceling his subscription and
switching over to Jeremy's razors he was
so ticked off with Harry's virtue
signaling nonsense that he was willing
to pay the extra money to have his
Jeremy's kit shipped to the UK where he
lives since then we've been copied on a
flood of breakup emails from our
listeners all telling Harry's and
Gillette what they can do with their
woke razors here's a new one uh reading
it now says hello I've been using
Harry's for many years and have enjoyed
your product however when you choose to
inject yourself into Political matters
and say that 50 of the country are
bigots you make it a very easy decision
for me to cancel why should half the
country have to tolerate open
discrimination simply for having a
different opinion the answer is that we
shouldn't and thanks to daily wire we no
longer have to I'll be giving my money
to someone who will use it for something
I support not a company that openly
despises me P.S I am a bald man and
shave my head three times per week so
you genuinely are missing out on a good
deal of money from me
now this man's follicle Fallout is
Harry's Financial loss but they have no
one to blame but themselves actions have
consequences and we will gladly take the
lead in holding woke companies like
Harry's Gillette Disney and all the rest
to account someone has to do it right
that's what we're doing right now when
you go to Jeremy's racers.com you can
get 40 off your Founders kit so head to
jeremy'sraisers.com and start shaving
woke free and don't forget to copy us on
your breakup email using reviews at
jeremy'srazors.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
day in our daily cancellation we will be
discussing comments about race which
were made by an NFL coach but we will
not be canceling the coach
now as you know in almost all cases if
this segment is focused on someone in
the professional sports world who said
something about race or politics or
social issues
um they will almost always be getting
canceled because it is nearly certain
that whatever they said it was
incredibly stupid virtue signaling
left-wing claptrap but not today
head coach of the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
Todd Bowles will be facing the
Pittsburgh Steelers this week and his
team will likely win by a couple of
scores not because the Bucks are all
that good but because the Steelers are
pathetically bad not really relevant to
anything to point that out but as a
Ravens fan I feel the need to make a
point of mentioning how bad the Steelers
are this year and they are really bad
but in any case uh the point most
relevant to the media to the media
anyway is that Todd Bowles is black and
Pittsburgh's head coach Mike Tomlin is
also black
two black men
facing off in the NFL historic
and if you leave aside the fact that we
see these kinds of matchups in every NFL
game every single weekend for the past I
don't know 50 years
if you leave that aside you could say
that we never see these kinds of
matchups they are historic
that's why the media wants to make a big
deal out of it and um they they point
out that although yes there are black
men in many positions on every NFL team
there are comparatively fewer NFL head
coaches who are black and having two
teams with black head coaches facing
each other therefore is monumental
both of these men
must understand how Monumental it is
they must they have to
and if they don't the media will remind
them and that's what these reporters try
to do for Todd Bowles during a press
conference yesterday which led to this
exchange listen
you and my Tomlin are two of the few
blackhead coaches in the league I wonder
what your relationship is like with them
and your thoughts on Steve Wilkes
joining that poll
I have a very good relationship with
Tomlin we don't look at
what color we are when we Coast against
each other we just know each other I
have a lot of very good white friends
that coach in this league as well and I
don't think it's a big deal as far as us
being coaching against each other I
think it's normal Wilkes got an
opportunity to do a good job hopefully
he does it and we coach ball we don't
look at color but you also understand
that representation matters too right
and that when young aspiring coaches or
even football players they see you guys
you know they see someone that looks
like them and they grew up like them
that has to mean something well when you
say you see you guys and look like them
and grow up like them means that we're
eyeballs to begin with and I think the
minute you guys start stop making a big
deal about it everybody else will as
well
that's great I love that so wow so Todd
Bowles it turns out hasn't spent much
time sitting around and meditating on
the significance of his opponent's skin
color as it relates to his own skin
color
he says it isn't a big deal and if you
guys the media stop making the big deal
he says everyone else would move on with
their lives too
so there are a few points uh here worth
noting first unsurprisingly
the reporter lecturing the black man
about why he ought to see more
significance in the racial dynamics of
this weekend's matchup that reporter is
a white woman notice that the
patronizing tone she uses you understand
that representation matters right you
understand that
and then she goes on to explain the
importance of black representation to a
black man
clay Travis over at outkick reports that
the reporter is Jenna Lane who works at
uh as a bucks correspondent for of
course ESPN who else in her write-up on
this exchange she makes she makes sure
to note again
just why Todd Bowles should care more
about the racial component of this
weekend's bucks Steelers game she writes
quote the NFL has come under increased
scrutiny in recent years for its lack of
black head coaches when roughly 70 of
the League's players are black following
wilkes's promotion there are four active
NFL head coaches who are black Wilkes
Boles Tomlin and Lovey Smith of Houston
Texans aside from those four three
additional head coaches are people of
color the Miami Dolphins Mike McDaniel
who's biracial the New York Jets is
Robert Sala who is of Lebanese descent
and the Washington commanders Ron Rivera
who is Latino
okay so that means
20 of NFL head coaches are quote people
of color
I'm not sure I quite see the problem
here meanwhile as she notes herself 70
of the players are black all in all a
hugely disproportionate number of those
making millions of dollars to work in
the NFL are black there is no racism
problem here
and if there was the numbers would
suggest that it that the racism problem
would be going the other way
yeah this will not stop Jenna lane from
pushing her narrative even if she has to
push it onto a black man against his
will
more specifically she is pressuring him
to push it for her
this is very often how it goes with the
left's racial narrative
that's what's so uh revealing about this
the white liberals
depend on non-white people to be their
puppets their ventriloquist dummies
repeating the lines that have been
assigned to them white liberals assume
from the outset that every non-white
person they meet will be willing and
eager to play that role
if you're not white they will presume
that they know ahead of time what your
basic outlook on life is what your
priorities are what your uh you know
what your values are what your political
stances are
any non-white person who does not play
their assumed role risks being ripped to
shreds for their lack of cooperation in
fact I expect that several lengthy think
pieces have already been written
explaining why Todd Bowles is a
self-hating white supremacist and uh
probably suspected Nazi sympathizer
the other thing we see from this
incident is how the left's racial
obsessive Obsession just makes
everything
so shallow and boring and dreary because
by far the least interesting or relevant
thing about the Steelers Bucks game
is that the two head coaches are black
but that's what they want to focus on
In fairness there's not a lot
interesting at all about the game
because both teams kind of suck but even
so the racial Dynamics are the least
interesting aspect out of all of it
now
it's not that the races of the coaches
are meaningless
um race is not nothing
your race is a fact about you it does
mean something it's important in its own
way because it's it's a fact about you
yet on the left they want to reduce you
entirely to these identity markers
you are nothing but the combination of
your race your sex your sexual
orientation your gender identity quote
unquote which is a made up and
meaningless category of course
they want us all to to go through life
as just like walking demographic
statistics
that's how they want the world to see us
and most importantly it's how they want
us to see ourselves
that's how Jenna Lane at ESPN wants Todd
Bowles to see himself
and that is why she is today certainly
not Todd Bowles but she is canceled and
that'll do it for us today uh thanks for
watching have a great weekend Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]